This is not only an important day; it is a very special day for us...
...because it goes back to the year 1900...
...when one of our founders, Charles Rolls, made a prophecy,...
...and that prophecy was that electric drive is a perfect fit because it's clean,...
...it's noiseless and once charging is able and is fixed of charging problem,...
...then this is the ideal propulsion for a car.
The reason why we went electric is that clients love it.
Clients want to move emission-free in city centers in a Rolls-Royce.
This is quite appealing.
I think it is one jigsaw in a bigger puzzle of our long-term sustainability.
So it's not meant to be "This washes now the brand in any way green."
Not at all.